Dans cette entreprise
de la banlieue milanaise,
se fabrique un des trophées
les plus convoités au monde.
La coupe qui sera remise aux gagnants
du Mondial de football au Qatar.
Un travail méticuleux,
de longue haleine.
C'est difficile, car regardez,
la coupe est surmontée d'un globe terrestre.
On doit reproduire la géographie
avec les détails voulus par le sculpteur.
Le sculpteur qui l'a créé en 1970,
travaillait ici.
Le trophée est entièrement fait à la main
par des ouvriers spécialisés,
comme Pietro.
Il a manipulé toutes les Coupes du monde
depuis celles du Mondial de France 98.
Je me sens tellement privilégié
de pouvoir toucher cette coupe.
Surtout pour moi,
car c'est une tradition familiale.
Mon père travaillait dans cette usine,
et après le savoir-faire
est passé de père en fils.
Le processus de fabrication est ancien,
complètement artisanal,
et implique le travail
d'une dizaine de personnes.
Il faut passer par la fusion des métaux,
puis le cisaillement,
le traitement chimique,
la taille de la pierre.
et le fignolage des contours.
Il y a toute une série d'étapes
à suivre et pour réussir,
il faut agir en équipe.
Comme une équipe de football !
Dernière étape, un traitement chimique
pour enlever les impuretés.
Et le bain d'or, 24 carats.
Ici, il y a des ondes électromagnétiques qui
vont coller les particules d'or sur la coupe.
On peut faire trois ou quatre bains d'or
en fonction de la couleur de la coupe.
Les gagnants reçoivent la copie plaqué or,
car le trophée original en or massif,
n'est utilisé que pour la cérémonie
de remise des prix.
Après chaque Mondial,
On nous renvoie à la coupe originale
pour la maintenance.
Et on voit bien que ça a été
une coupe qui a été célébrée.
Elle a des marques, des taches,
et des petites égratignures
par ci par là.
50 ans après sa création,
la Coupe du Monde n'a pas pris une ride,
et attend, impatiente de voir,
qui la brandira au Qatar,
le 18 décembre prochain.